a day after his budget proposal
President Biden hailed a better than
expected jobs report as evidence of
economic progress but the robust pace
could complicate the federal reserve's
aggressive plan to tame inflation the
U.S economy added a solid 311 thousand
jobs in February the unemployment rate
though unexpectedly jumped to 3.6
percent in February in January it had
dipped to 3.4 percent its lowest level
since 1969. Christina raffini is at the
White House with more on all of this
Christina good morning
good morning Jeff well one of the
reasons that unemployment rate ticked up
slightly is more people have entered the
workforce looking for jobs now that
could be a good thing it could be a sign
of confidence or it could just be a
reflection in Rising consumer prices
today's job numbers is clear our economy
is moving in the right direction
speaking in the Roosevelt room President
Biden was bullish on the latest jobs
report which says the economy added more
than 300 000 of them in February nearly
a hundred thousand more than predicted
and that's really good news people who
were staying out of the job market this
is a particularly good news are now
getting back into the job market
but the strong job market is bad news
for the federal reserve's efforts to
curb inflation without price stability
the economy does not work for anyone in
particular earlier this week fed
chairman Jerome Powell told Congress the
central bank will continue to raise
rates our administration's top economic
priority remains bringing down inflation
and testifying on Capitol Hill Friday
treasury secretary Janet Yellen said
despite some progress more work needs to
be done Yellen was also on the hill to
pitch President Biden's new 6.8 trillion
dollar budget which would increase
military spending Shore up entitlement
programs like Medicare and Social
Security and fund a wide range of social
programs all while taking steps to
reduce the deficit that includes by
reforming our tax code to ensure no
billionaire pays a lower tax rate than a
teacher and a firefighter in this
country Republicans have called it debt
on arrival taxpayers are now asked in
this budget to hand the IRS another 4
43.2 billion I have to ask is that a
joke but Mr Biden's budget is part of a
long history of unpassable presidential
Financial prescriptions president
shouldn't take it personally most
presidential budgets for DOA in the
Senate would like to do our own work
now realistically these budgets are
usually just jumping off points for
negotiations one of the things they
still have to work out is a deal to
raise the debt ceiling the U.S
government is set to stop being able to
pay its debts around June now Janet
Yellen said yesterday on the hill
default would be quote financially
catastrophic Michelle this time of year
always a tense time Christine raffini
thank you